Welcome to our talk who's an NLP expert
Lessons Learned From building an
in-house QA system
um yeah my name is Nico killing next to
me is standing Alina and we are both
working for sign years a small data
science consultancy doing all kinds of
things like business intelligence data
engineering and of course machine
learning and we also got excited of the
NLP topic and basically had the idea of
building a small QA system for ourselves
at when we basically started we couldn't
see how crazy the whole field evolved so
basically we started with our project a
little bit before the first commit of
long chain a library which is now out
there with 25 000 GitHub Stars so it's
really crazy how fast everything went
afterwards
so basically the whole timeline to just
visualize that
um we started pre the new era and that's
also one big claim I want to make sure
here everyone settled on we won't talk
about chat GPT and how you integrate it
in your system we will have some
interesting takeaways hopefully if you
want to do something like that but
because you will probably need a couple
of things in a similar way but so we are
excited about it as well we also
planning to integrate it and stuff but
we haven't done it yet and we won't talk
about this here just a small remark
otherwise yeah
um so what is basically a sinus QA we
had the idea that we want to give our
employees an easy access to our internal
Knowledge Management but we didn't want
to create like a new confidence page or
a new sites we have to maintain we
basically wanted to use what we have so
basically some documents which are
living somewhere online and our chat
system like slack messages and stuff so
no additional effort of documenting our
knowledge and also integrating it into
our existing Communications channels
which is mostly Slack and I always like
to better show something than long speak
about it so therefore let me quickly
show you our system and hope that
everything works
[Music]
um
so basically I can ask it any question
so it's germ so uh
so basically we can ask it some
questions we are interested in and
hopefully it will reply soon
um
yeah that's basically our source there
or
um
let's see whether it gets that one
um so basically I'm saying who's who are
the developers of our internal source
board and yeah so he's here referencing
now a slack message
um from intern and I can also click
there and go and see what happened there
and get like more detailed information
on this so basically that's the idea of
what we want to leverage not all
examples are working that great of
course but
um yeah I want to give you a nice
impression what we're doing there so
what will this talk be about it will be
of how you integrate heterogeneous data
sources like for example long documents
and really small chat messages you have
which are really verbose
of how we evaluate a different kind of
retrieval and reader systems about the
differences of extractive and
abstractive QA and also how to integrate
it into a slackbot and with that I pass
over to Alina yeah thank you very much
Nico and welcome from my side as well
before we jump right into the details
let's first take a look at the
architecture behind the board in order
to be able to perform a question
answering we first need data in our case
these are messengers from different
select channels and two drive documents
during the ATL process we extract this
data and transfer them into Vector
documents using language models
depending on the data source the data is
additionally enriched with semantic
information
afterwards we can we can answer
questions by using om Source
Technologies like the retriever reader
pipeline from Haystack
while the chatbot users can ask that
question and we can collect feedback on
the answer
as last step this data such as question
answer and feedback and richest media
information will be stored in a database
to be used for model optimization one
last week note the components ATL VBA
database QA API and slackboard are
executed in a kubernetes cluster in
azure
so let's go into the detail as I just
mentioned data is one of the most
important component for
um question answering when using the
data special attention must be paid to
do very different data sources so we
cannot load simply simply load data in
the database and perform a question
answering so we must do data preparation
steps slack messages for example are
very unstructured data it is not unusual
that many messages are written per day
by different users
as a rest of an extreme large amount of
data accumulates
slack messages contain a lot of meta
information that you also timestamp
Channel idea channel name and so on
however sometimes methods are written
carelessly there are also some messages
that have no relevant content such as
images which you can see at this picture
and separate emojis or they contain only
short-lived information this data is
spam for us um for us which we classify
later as such
select messages often have to structure
threats with supplies essentially the
handling of replies is very difficult so
we must ask ourselves how to store
replies in the database to keep the
context
it is also problematic if users answer
to previous messages with an extra
message instead of replying this way we
also lose the context
in addition we had some other air
special formats such as reactions on
messages which you can see here and
polls created by plugins which you can
see above so we mask ourselves how to
deal with this type of information
the opposite on slack matches are g12
documents which are structured data
on the one hand they contain less meter
information but on the other hand they
have a structure through headings
however the documents often have very
different and long text lengths which is
not useful for a question answering
because all the data should have
approximately the same length
therefore we split long g12 documents
into sub-documents and there are two
ways to do this splitting by a certain
number of words or splitting by the head
instruction we use the second variant
this way we also keep the context in the
paragraph
sometimes however the G drive documents
may have outdated information if they
are not continuously updated and this
may result in incorrect information
being extracted
um
and it's also problematic if images are
used between text blocks which you can
sorry which you can see here so we need
to consider how to deal with this type
of information currently we remove such
images in addition to the text documents
there are other special forms such as
for example PowerPoint presentations
which require M special data processing
methods
so but how does the reading of the day
their work on the technical level for
the extraction of the slack Masters we
use the chatbot therefore the chatbot
must remember the corresponding Channel
and it requires the use of the slack API
one method of the API allows us to read
messages without replies due to this
fact we must extract replies via a
separate method but this often leads to
rate limits especially for many messages
so um we must Implement Implement a rate
limit Handler to prevent the application
from crashing
to read teach life documents we use the
drive API from Google
um if you want to download a document we
can add our search documents via file
name or load all documents from before
them
since we have different document types
such as g12 documents versus Microsoft
documents including PDF files we need
Different download methods so I can see
the handling of heterogeneous data
sources with individual data and chest
patterns it's very important and it
requires subject-specific data
preparation
for classifying what a select message is
Spam or not spam who uses that will
modem set with an efficient and prompt
free framework for a few short fine
tuning of sentence installers and it
achieves high accuracy with small
training data sets
during the implementation we tested
several experiments with a total of
three different data sets the default
data set has the same number of data
points in a training set for both
classes
in the more training data not spam class
we use twice the number of data points
for the notepam class and for spam class
because in the data in a balanced data
set we had many false positives but for
Trader classify a spare method as not
spammed in the other way around
therefore we gave more weight to the not
um spam class
in the bell statuset with threshold
variant we use a balanced data set
together with this threshold to classify
as band message
after we um sorry after we performed the
experiments we could calculate the mean
accuracy and mean recall over the five
Training runs for each data set
to select a model for our production
system we consider both values and take
that model that has both High currency
and high recall and in this image you
can see two paragraphs in the left
paragraph you can see the mean accuracy
is plotted on the y-axis and the x-axis
shows the number of data points in the
training data set and in the right graph
there is the mean recall plotted
so um we can see that the
we can see that um the model trend on 32
the um training data points for the spam
gas on the 64 training data points for
the notepad class has both high accuracy
and higher quick growth and that's the
reason why we use this modern our
productive system
okay
um yeah
okay okay
um in addition we categorize our slack
messages into different categories such
as expert questions or when
announcements currently we don't use
this information further however you can
see in
this diagram very well that the text
Channel contains a lot of news about
Technologies and questions after experts
and the channel channel is more used for
social interaction and announcements
so after we clarify the databases it's
not time to have a look behind the mqa
model
for the QA model we use a two-stage
retriever reader pipeline from haystack
the first station was the retriever that
identifies relevant document candidates
based on a question and a virtual
database
the relevance of the documents is
evaluated for example using TF IDF bm25
on embedding retriever
after the review has selected the
document candidates they are transferred
to the reader together with the question
in the second stage
their cheetah can now extract potential
answer phrases from this document
candidates
and create a ranking using deep learning
based relevant scoring depending on the
confidence score of the reader's first
answer the user shown one or three
answers
so let's take a close look at the reader
and
retriever
yeah
proteas can be divided into two classes
they are the term as retriever or swast
retriever which based on
on Counting the occurrences offered this
rests in various sparse vectors with
lengths equal to the vocabulary results
such algorithms are very simple fast and
well explainable however they rely on
the exact keyword matches between the
query in the text so for example the
questions who are the developers of the
sinus QA bot and who built the question
answering chatbot would lead to
different answers also the use of
synonyms doesn't work well here
therefore the development of
vector-based retrievers also called
Dance retrievers occur appeared over the
years
this usernal network models to create
dense embedding vectors
as a result they capture semantic
similarity but also have more
computational intensive usage as well as
initial training so we can summarize
that term-based retrievers are very good
stuff but vector-based routers often
perform better in the real world
and in
important Hands-On for the evaluation of
achievas the evaluation data set must
reflect real user questions
nevertheless we tested both types of
divas and combine the magician limb in
various experiments we found that a
combination of both best bars the
advantage of combining the tools that we
now have multiple views of the documents
so it's better to select the top 10
routers from multiple the top 10
documents from multiple retrievers then
to take the top 10 from only one
retriever because then we have different
views of the documents
humanly we use three different receivers
being 25 as a term based retriever a
vector-based retriever for g12 documents
and another web to away so trivial for
both g12 and Slack
adding an additional retriever for G
drive documents is very important
because we have many slack messages in
our database which you can see in this
plot and therefore more select documents
are selected as a relevant document
candidates however since the most
questions will be related to G drive
documents we all always want to include
G drive documents in the reader
and to implement the use of multiple
retrievers we use the pipeline which
joins the results of the retrievers and
gives the best 10 documents to the
reader
the number of
um top elements that are given to the
reader can be changed but this will have
an impact on the performance of the
model
after we selected the relevant document
candidates and the reader can now expect
potential answer phrases from this
document candidates
and the readers also available in two
common types
on the one hand there's the extractor
reader where the answer is extracted
from a given context
this allows me to determine exactly the
source from which the answer comes comes
and the labeling of um test questions is
very easy
however not always um exactly one answer
can be extracted as important to the
answer phrases and if you can imagine
this um
you know um
and therefore the on the other hand they
are the abstracted reader which
generates answers from multiple
perspectives
this um
leads to generation of rich and more
accurate answers however it's um this is
also more difficult to create suitable
labels for determining the inference and
to measure the similarity between the
label and protection
for us it's currently okay that we um
still use an extracted freedom however
we planned that chatubity will later
provide the abstractive power to combine
extracted information
during the implementation of the chatbot
it became apparent that for testing the
model's performance and evaluation
dashboard with testus cases is critical
for identifying problem cases and
therefore we use stream stream it allows
us a transforms file systems to
interactive web applications
to calculate the similarity between the
prediction and the target we use the
Rouge F1 score Rush is a set of metrics
for the evaluation of both Atomic
automatically generated
um summaries and machine translations
based on this score we can now determine
submissions about the number of correct
and incorrect answers
furthermore track the position of the
document with the correct answer in the
retriever to determine how well the
retriever entry they perform
the challenge in testing the model's
performance lies in what constitutes
good or bad labeling because the choice
of the test questions influence the
metrics so therefore the metrics should
be considered critically for example we
wonder at ypm25 works well for us until
we realized that many of our test
questions are very close to the wording
of the paragraph from which the answer
should be extracted
in various numbers the dashboard also
includes some visualization such as for
example this plot and this diagram we
can see very well that for most
questions the document containing the
correct answer is among the first
documents of the retrieval this is very
good because that means that the
document with the correct answer is
given to the reader and there is a
realistic chance that the reader will
extract the correct answer any documents
that are in position 11
or higher will not given to the reader
what we're still missing is an interface
for users where they can answer where
they can write their questions and
therefore we use um as like chatbot
which is integrated into the workspace
from sinus
users can ask the questions on both and
direct messages and
um
channels and when you when a user asks a
question in the channel the chatbot must
be mentioned directly to prevent it from
responding to questions that are not
intended for it
after a user asks a question the chatbot
answers it by making a simple API call
to the QA Pipeline and the user can then
confirm the enthus court or make a
escort or make a correction using the
buttons in the chat
for the implementation of the bot we use
um the framework bot which is common
recommended by um slack and allows us to
Quick Start in the programming among
other things the um chatbot
reacts to so-called events so for
example if a user opens the direct
message with the word an individualized
welcome message appears which you can
see in this picture
all the communication and so this
includes app interactions and events
currently run over web server connection
which is called socket Morton's leg boy
provides for this proposal socket mode
handling Handler and the advantage of
using socket mode is that we don't need
a public static HTTP endpoint and the
development behind the firewalls
possible
as I mentioned earlier we use
um buttons to get feedback from the user
if you can send this images
and if an answer is marked as wrong the
user has the option to give the correct
answer
um if yeah to give the correct answer
to start this data we use the object
relation mapping technique and to
mapping the correction to the answer we
use the time Sim of the answer from the
bot
so let's summarize the most important
aspects again Haystack and Vivid will
work well in contribute the handling of
future status with specific reprocessing
Finance is very important and we have
all seen that very different talk deck
we have also in a very different
document lengths are problematic
um G drive documents should be very well
structured and we need a filtering and
down sampling of the high quantity but
we're both lack messages
and in evaluation good evaluation
dashboard with test use cases is
critical to identify critical problem
cases
okay and as said we don't talk about
chpt but of course I want to outline the
vision basically how we think things
will work probably for us and many
others as well and the nice thing is
that basically we have all the stuff
above already so basically the data
Centric work where you have like your
documents you need to run them through
some embedding pipeline to create
document embeddings either using
something like sentence Transformer or
maybe an API like open AI or cohere to
write them into a vector database that
all stays just the same
and Below basically we just add like a
new endpoint in front probably the
default open AI endpoint and then allow
it to talk to either our extractive
reader or the other idea would basically
to have like a retriever which gets all
the documents and then have like another
API call to chat GPT or something to
give it the idea of okay please
summarize those 10 documents for me
regarding this question and then to hand
that one into a final one to basically
work with the context context length
yeah that's basically our idea for the
future and we are really happy if you
have some questions for us
[Applause]
okay yeah so but you have some Force
how does this work okay
so
did anyone ask a question on slido
okay I can't see it I will come to you
um so I have several questions actually
thank you for your advice
[Music]
um
I was thinking about you said that you
have images in your documents have you
thought about including them as well by
using an OCR and then including them to
the document database
okay so so yeah the questions were we
talking about screenshots because OCR
probably makes only events there
um
I guess that might get confusing rather
because those are rather screenshots
from like the the document hey or like
different pages within Azure or whatever
and if you include basically all the
text in there I guess it might be rather
confusing but otherwise we thought of
basically getting the idea of this image
basically say okay this is a screenshot
or this is whatever and to include that
yeah that would be one definite idea
area but we haven't done it
okay maybe a quick second question um so
how often do you update your document
database so do you update it regularly
or yes recordly so basically we have a
runner all the time who basically calls
the API of slack and also of Google docs
which runs I think every five minutes
and just checks whether there is like a
most updated timestamp and then
um you know we'll update those but you
have to be a little bit careful for
example for the documents which we split
up by the hierarchy key so if the
document changes like completely which
doesn't hopefully happen that often you
might have problems with your idea and
identifying the paragraphs again
okay so thank you very much for the nice
talk I have a question uh So currently
the question answering chatbot works for
German right yes yes and what it takes
if you want to make it work for another
language
probably not too much you basically have
to switch to a multilingual model which
we will do anyway if we go to uh to tptu
a similar one
um in the beginning we start or
basically actually the embeddings are
also already by a bilingual model of a
German English one because basically it
was the best open source we found there
on hugging face
um so yeah we could even try it in
English I'm not sure yeah but but it
means that you can already borrow some
of the components of the German uh boat
for English or you want to you need to
make it from the scratch
no we definitely don't need to make it
from scratch basically you so there are
two components which are critical one
creating the embeddings for the vector
database that one the embedder has to be
multilingual for that and then also the
reader basically has to be a
multi-lingual trained model and aside of
that
um nothing changes I guess but is the
embedded agnostic regarding the language
yes so basically it depends on the model
you put and if the model is multilingual
it's agnostic to the language
okay thank you very much
okay
thank you how they would search works
how you aggregate the different
algorithms I mean how you evaluate that
they're in practice the retrievers yes
they you said that you are using for
example the sentence better but also
bm25 you have a neighborhood search yeah
then how do you Aggregate and how you
evaluate that so
basically we took the time to generate
like I think 200 300 yeah 300
um question answer pairs but basically
the process is also important because we
basically looked into certain documents
and then had the question okay what
could we ask to that document and that
also led to us using the same phrases we
had in the document in the question
again which gave a boost to our bm25 uh
yeah Retriever and with that you need to
be a little bit careful so basically
always evaluated against those 300 test
cases we had and yeah one important
finding we had is that often a retriever
has the correct document because then
now we know the correct document for
those ones
um on rather the first or the second
position but
or like really long tail so the third
fourth fifth position often doesn't help
us and therefore we use like different
retrievers now and we basically just
concatenate them together by basically
the rank so basically we take the first
rank from the first document there is a
already prepared component for that in
Haystack
yes
um thanks for the great talk uh two
questions actually the first one is you
mentioned the problem of outdated data
do you have some way to deal with that
and the second question
um can you elaborate a bit more on the
pre-processing step you do with
classification and metadata and how it
exactly comes into the pipeline is it
just a filtering step
um and yeah try to elaborate a bit more
than that and also if you take it away
how much performance uh loss do you have
if you have a feeling for that thank you
okay make that quick so basically the
one is basically write everything in the
database right now but we flag the ones
where we think it might be spam and so
and then we use a pre-filter within the
document search basically to filter
those ones out
um
yeah and regarding the update procedure
maybe you can see some outdated
informations more in that the employees
don't updated the documents in our h5m
so yeah it's still a human problem that
we have to do manually and to update the
information in our documents
yeah and I think we're on the time but
we can maybe chat a little bit later in
the audience yeah thank you so much and
please give another round of applause to
the speaker